starting from vinomen's uh
self-replicating automata that you
mentioned
it's just a beautiful idea so that's at
the heart of all of this in the stack I
described so one student will Langford
made these micro robots out of little
parts that then we're using for miana's
bigger robots up through this hierarchy
and it's really realizing this idea of
the self-reproducing automata so van
Neumann when I complained about the vi
Neumann architecture it's not fair to
Von Neumann because he never claimed it
as his architecture he really wrote
about it in this one fairly Dreadful
memo that led to all sorts of lawsuits
and fights and about the early days of
computing he did beautiful work on
reliable computation and unreliable
devices and towards the end of his life
what he studied was how and I have to
say this precisely how a computation
communicates its own construction yeah
so beautiful so a computation can store
a description of how to build itself but
now there's a really hard problem which
is how if you have that in your mind how
do you transfer it and wake up a thing
that then can contain it
um so how do you give birth to a thing
that knows how to make itself and so
um with Stan ulam he invented cellular
automata as a way to simulate these
uh but that was theoretical now the work
I'm describing in my lab is is
fundamentally how to realize it how to
re um realize self-reproducing uh
automata and so you know this is
something van Neumann thought very
deeply and very beautiful of beautifully
about theoretically and it's right at
this intersection it it's not
communication or computation or
fabrication
it's right at this intersection where
communication and computation meets
fabrication
now the reason self-reproducing automata
intellectually is so important because
this is the foundation of life this is
really just understanding the essence of
how to life and in effect we're trying
to create life and non-living material
the reason it's so important
technologically is because that's how
you scale capacity that's how you can
make an elephant from a ribosome because
the assemblers make assemblers so simple
building blocks yeah that inside
themselves contain the information how
to build more building blocks and so
between each other construct arbitrarily
complex objects right now let me give
you the numbers so let me relate this to
right now we're living in AI Mania
explosion time
let me relate that to what we're talking
about
a hundred petaflop computer
which is a current generation uh
supercomputer not quite the biggest ones
uh does 10 to the 17 Ops per second
your brain does 10 to the 17 Ops per
second it has about 10 to the 15
synapses and they run at about 100 Hertz
so as of a year or two ago
the compute the performance of a big
computer matched a brain so you could
view AI as a breakthrough but the real
story is
um within about a year or two ago and
let's see that that the super computer
has about 10 to the 15 transistors in
the processors 10 to the 15 transistors
in the memory which is the synapses in
your brain so the real breakthrough was
the computers match the computational
capacity of a brain and so we'd be sort
of derelict if they couldn't do about
the same thing but now the reason I'm
mentioning that is
the
chip Fab making the supercomputer is
placing about 10 to the 10 transistors a
second
while you're digesting your lunch right
now you're make you're placing about 10
to the 18 parts per second
um there's an eight order of magnitude
difference not so in computational
capacity it's done we've caught up
but there's eight orders of magnitude
difference in the rate at which biology
can build versus state-of-the-art
manufacturing can build
and that distinction is what we're
talking about that distinction is not
analog but this deep sense of digital
fabrication of embodying codes in
construction so a description doesn't
describe a thing but the description
becomes the thing